yo andrew i have a business proposition
okay would you rather give five hundred
thousand dollars
or
go to dinner with jay-z bro all these
[ __ ] idiots
that are saying i would rather go to
dinner with jay-z like he's gonna like
bestow this [ __ ] business wisdom on
you as if you could do anything with it
that's why you broke yeah you're gonna
take 500 000 when it's sitting right
there the first piece of information he
would say is uh take five hundred
thousand dollars any time someone offers
it to you
he's gonna call you an idiot for not
taking a 500. yeah
like it's such a no-brainer and also the
reason
jay-z is so successful is not just
because of his big business acumen it's
because he happened to be
the best at a thing that was really
popular yeah yeah yeah right it's like
going
to business it's like going to dinner
with lebron james it's like too many
advice for me he's like yeah b68 b6a
260.
a perfect physical athletic specimen
photographic memory genius
i don't even know how good a businessman
jay-z actually is he might be good but
on a fair scale where he doesn't have
any skills like you know you ever see
those like stock guys or like some like
rich dude who's like five six and he's
just fat [ __ ] bald that guy's a
business man
okay that guy got nothing else right but
what's going on up here making good
[ __ ] moves right jay-z
is a genius rapper who also is really
good at business
but a lot of that is predicated on how
genius he is at being a rapper i mean
how much of jay-z's wealth has come out
completely outside of his celebrity
status as a rapper hmm i think he made
way more money outside of rap but but
it's still a little continuously
leveraging yeah
yeah but he did it brilliantly yeah but
van lathan said it best he tweeted i'd
rather take five hundred thousand
dollars and have dinner with jesus
which that's like it's 500 000
everything i have dinner with jesus no i
go jesus christ i'll go with 500. use my
[ __ ] turn water into wine you
don't think he could turn 20 into
something yeah
forgiveness when i die and i'm gonna
take 500 000 now and jay-z is still
hanging with like jack dorsey he's
learning still he's doing this yeah
except he's dope he's getting jack
dorsey to buy his company yeah exactly
how much you care about blackboard
will you buy my failing streaming
service yeah
that'd be kind of boss move but yeah i
don't know why the [ __ ] that was even a
conversation yeah i don't get it
it's what you want
they want to seem like they got some
[ __ ] you don't got everybody says 500
000. everybody's not a [ __ ] [ __ ] but
you want to see him like you on the next
level so you're like y'all don't get it
you turn it down
i think people that don't have success
sometimes will think oh i'm just one
piece of advice away mm-hmm or i'm just
like one thing i'm one it's not me it's
not my hard work now you're 500 thousand
dollars away from 500.
it's not my knowledge it's just that i
don't have that knowledge yeah and so
they're like oh if i can just get in
front of this guy i'll change my whole
these are the people that buy seminars
you know what i mean like they're like
oh if i sit down with this guy which in
front of some seminars are actually
super helpful yeah but there's a hell of
people that are like i'm going to go to
the seminar it's going to change my life
see that guy go to the paul that tick
tock i just sent the video to alex
that's fake though what do you mean
it's not real
it is whether even if it's fake that
part where he's saying logan like i just
need connections and logan's like what
are you talking about connections he's
like you have connections like hey jake
what are you what are you saying what do
you what can you do for me he's like i'm
interested what can you do for me and
the guy's like i don't know man i just i
just want to learn he said well you're
not offering me anything that's the same
thing morgan's talking about yeah yeah
with these kinds of people who are like
i just need one person what i'm saying
is this guy like the way it was promoted
is i quit my job to go work for logan
paul and it's like no
i don't even think you quit your job i
just think you thought it would be a
really funny tick tock if you snuck into
this event oh yeah that part is not with
logan paul but the interaction with
logan is true yeah
how logan is reacting yes yeah what he's
saying no
i think it would go there that's my
point yeah i don't know it's not logan's
not in on it making a content like
making some videos no logan's being real
with a guy i think he's saying good
things he's just but he knows that the
guy's trying to just get off on some
cloud chasing video yeah the guy this is
his version of cloud he's like okay i'm
gonna front and then fake cry saying
that oh i quote and now we're talking
about it he was [ __ ] right yeah he's
absolutely right but i do know a lot of
people that are actually like this
they'll just quit their job and then
well because they think one i think they
want handouts and they're like yo if i
just in front of this person i'll get
the hand out and like they'll make me a
star yeah like a lot of people want to
just be made into something yeah yeah if
i sit down with jay-z like he'll make me
the head of whatever like yeah i'll sit
down at the p diddy lecture and be like
yo give me a job i'll do this like i'll
sit with garyvee and be like yo give me
a thing give me something yeah but then
they never think yo what can i give
you know what i mean and so they're like
oh i'm gonna sit down with jay-z and
he's gonna give me something yeah like
they don't think what they can do like
he didn't even know what he could do
yeah logan's like what would you do for
me i'll do anything you better have a
specific [ __ ] thing do you think you
have what it takes no i don't yeah it's
like why because everybody wants help
like i get that in the i'm sure we all
get it like indians like do just reach
out it's like yo you got i want to work
for you you got to hire me and i was
like all right what do you do yeah
i'm j i can pick up anything
i'm eager to learn my least favorite
response people go yo i'll be i'll be
your ass [ __ ] like i'll do whatever and
i'm like no yeah we don't want a [ __ ]
yeah and tell me why i need it yeah like
tell me oh [ __ ] this isn't working as
well as it could you could be making so
much more money on yes this is way
better over here i can make the [ __ ]
lighting work i can do whatever it is i
get all these edits i have this system i
can do this like just tell me something
that you can improve about my business
something concrete all about something
abstract like i'm willing to learn just
mention that we're not hiring right now
so this is not encouraging a bunch of
people because last episode i said
something and god damn [ __ ] it
was like yo i'm on patreon
yeah then they hit me trouble yeah
yeah but that would be the one thing i
would like cancel someone for if i was
hiring for a job like you know people
like go back through tweets and they'll
like be like oh we can't hire you said
this insensitive joke yeah if they said
they would have dinner with jay-z i
would
100 i believe you're just not fit to
work at our company
this is what you think success is
i mean what are you even gonna do at
dinner like how do you know he's gonna
give you any information like what if
he's just gonna he don't want to talk to
you yeah like i like my wine and i he
what if he brought a friend he brought
beany seagull like
you know what you're gonna catch up at
this dinner it's like a cross it's like
when you hear j cole tell
his story he's like oh hey i was
grinding or whatever the case is i met
jay-z and then the rest is history yeah
that's what people think is gonna happen
yeah they don't realize that like he was
making his own beats exactly rapping
better than anybody he's a prolific
artist prolific artist and then jay-z
noticed how prolific he was and was like
oh i think that we can make some money
together i think this guy's a real
hustler and i think he's got a skill but
he did all the hard work first and then
presented it to someone who could
potentially help him do the work first
what is the uh the [ __ ] great chris
rock joke it's like any time i see
somebody uh on the side of the highway
pushing their car by themselves oh yeah
i'll go help there's always somebody
that stops and goes to help but if
you're just sitting on the side of the
highway with a sign saying help me
nobody ever stops yeah and it's
something about like you doing it you
starting it people are going to be drawn
to that and attracted to that we do it
all the time with podcasts we think guys
got a good podcast or a good idea we're
going to put the sauce on it yeah so in
that case maybe i'd take back what i
said if you have some business that's
fire and you're like yo it's a streaming
thing it's going to be a huge thing and
i could get dinner with jay-z and i
could maybe get him to invest i'm like
all right um
no i take the 500 000 that's the
investment yeah jay-z not gonna give you
more than 500 000.
maybe give you a hundred thousand shark
tank you might not have like the wisdom
to manage to five hundred thousand then
he just blows it and then it goes to
waste yeah jay-z let me give you equity
dawg if you goofy shark tank it actually
that's interesting yeah you you're
basically put in front of you have a
business what you want is investment and
a partner for your business yes that is
interesting and it's a successful have
you seen shark tank you know who gets
the money the people with the [ __ ]
sales and the numbers the people who
don't really need the money the guys who
come with a great idea and no sales they
will pass almost every year yeah that's
actually true or they'll give you like
25 000.
that's cute what is it making yeah
that's always the first question what
are your sales what's proprietary yeah
yeah
but that is interesting yeah we want to
know the numbers like at the end of the
day like that's cute that you got this
little [ __ ] dream that's what happens
at shark tank oh you guys have a little
dream and a cool idea and a nice little
logo that's adorable how much money is
it making but your sales just aren't
there and for that reason i'm out every
time you know at least one of them is
saying that and that's it push the car
first prove that your [ __ ] works prove
you don't need these [ __ ] there
is nothing more attractive than a
[ __ ] that don't need you okay
especially as an investor in businesses
right when a [ __ ] don't need you
now you got to win them over you got to
be like i can help you you got the
investor convincing you
that he can help you make more money
that's it
that's like these independent artists
that eventually sign with the label they
get the biggest [ __ ] check oh yeah
right because you prove you don't need
the label
you